on the question of whether the united  states is poised to overcome its  long-term debt cycle issues  um  figure it this way  this generation unfortunately  is burdened  by debts that have been given by the  prior generation  and those are obligations  and either they will be paid back  in hard money and that'll be painful  because that means that people will have  to spend less than they earn  so  that's going to be tough  or you're going to the only way you can  deal with this debt  is to earn more than you spend  and we're going to have to change our  behaviors that requires a lot it means  you either have to work harder or more  productively to earn more than you spend  or you're going to have to cut your  spending  and that's just the way it is